si es mujer y tiene fibroides uterinos
su médico puede recomendar la remoción
robótica del tumor fibroides también
conocida como miomectomía robótica
sus órganos reproductivos incluyen su
vagina
cuello uterino
útero
trompas de falopio
y ovarios
un libro y de uterino también conocido
como ley o miomas es un tumor no
cancerígeno en su útero comienza un
crecimiento anormal en las células en su
pared uterina
los fibroides uterinos crecen en su
lugar y no se esparcen o hacen
metástasis a otras partes de su cuerpo
los cuatro tipos principales de
fibroides uterinos son
intramurales que crecen dentro de la
pared de su útero
sub zero sa que crece en la pared
exterior de su útero
sub mucosa que crece en la pared interna
de su útero
y pedúnculo que crece en racimo adjunto
a la pared interna o externa de su útero
el tamaño y ubicación de sus fibroides
uterinos pueden causar síntomas como un
sangrado menstrual pesado
sangrado irregular entre períodos
dolor de la espalda baja
y dolor durante el sexo
orinar con frecuencia
llenura y agrandamiento del abdomen
inferior
y complicaciones del embarazo
antes del procedimiento se colocará una
vía intravenosa
usted puede recibir antibióticos por vía
y ve para disminuir la posibilidad de
infecciones
se le brindará anestesia general para
ponerla a dormir y bloquear el dolor
durante el procedimiento
se insertará un tubo respiratorio por la
boca y en sus vías respiratorias para
ayudarle a respirar durante la operación
su cirujano hará una pequeña incisión en
o encima de su ombligo e insertar a un
tubo llamado un puerto gas de dióxido de
carbono pasará a través de este puerto
hacia su abdomen el gas inflar a su
abdomen dándole a su cirujano más
espacio para ver y mover las
herramientas quirúrgicas
después de que su abdomen se infle una
cámara de alta definición será insertada
en este puerto
su cirujano hará incisiones para puertos
adicionales para instrumentos robóticos
así como para instrumentos utilizados
por asistentes del paciente
un asistente insertará todas las
herramientas robóticas a través de estos
puertos a diferencia de los instrumentos
laparoscópicos estándar estas
herramientas pueden rotar 360 grados y
tienen más flexibilidad que la muñeca
humana
sentado en una consola especial su
cirujano manejará los brazos robóticos y
la cámara con controles tipo vara y
pedales para pies
una computadora traducir a los
movimientos exactos de los dedos de su
cirujano en movimientos precisos de las
herramientas quirúrgicas
en el mismo momento un sistema de visión
de alta definición brindará una vista
estereoscópica tridimensional del área
quirúrgica
su cirujano localizar a su fibroides
uterinos y lo inyectará con medicación
para reducir el sangrado
a continuación su cirujano
cuidadosamente cortará alrededor de los
bordes de su fibroides y lo remover a su
útero no será removido
los bordes restantes de su útero serán
cerrados con suturas
al final del procedimiento se cierran
las pequeñas incisiones en la piel con
puntos grapas pegamento quirúrgico o con
vendajes de cierre de piel
después del procedimiento se le retirará
el tubo respiratorio y se le trasladará
al área de recuperación para ser
monitoreada
le darán medicamentos contra el dolor si
fuese necesario
usted puede ser dada de alta del
hospital el mismo día en el lapso de un
día después del procedimiento